So I remember seeing on the web
page a link called Cricket, so
I am going to start and
actually find this link.
Again, I open the web order.
>> Headings menu.
>> You notice I'm on Headings, so
I'm going to left arrow to Links.
>> Links menu.
>> And I begin typing cricket.
>> 9 items, link, link, cricket.
>> Here it is,
I'm going to press Enter, and
the focus will go straight
to the cricket link.
>> Link, cricket, cricket.
>> Now I'm going to activate this
link by pressing Ctrl+Opt+Space bar.
This is a voice over shortcut key.
>> Press link, cricket, cricket,
with cricket, Wikipedia,
the free encyclopedia page
has 1,079 links, 52 headings,
4 form controls,
12 tables, 14 landmarks.
>> So again,
you may have noticed that voice over
just pronounced the page summary.
It told me how many headings, links,
tables, and form fields on the page
there are, which is a lot, there's like
1,000 links or something like that.
But we're not interested
in links anymore,
what we're going to do next
is look at the form fields.
So I'm going to open web order again.
>> Headings menu, Links menu.
>> And
arrow right until I reach Form Controls.
>> Form Controls menu.
>> From here, I want to search for
a form field with a label of search
because I'm going to be searching for
something,
>> 13 items, 2, 1 item.
>> Here it is.
>> Search insertion at beginning of
text, search, edit text.
>> I will press Enter key
to jump to that field.
>> Search insertion at beginning
of text, search, edit text.
Search access key available, F.
>> You've noticed Screen Reader told
me the label of this field, but it also
told me that there is an access key, or
in other words, the shortcut key that I
can press to quickly jump to this search
field from anywhere on the web page.
If you're interested in
how access keys work,
please look into instructor's notes for
more information.
So what I'll do here,
I'll type the word Udacity.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Udacity, Wikipedia, the free
encyclopedia page has 346 links,
16 headings, 4 form controls,
2 tables, 13 landmarks.
>> Notice how Screen Reader pronounced
the word Udacity as Uda city.
This is a pretty common occurrence
because the speech synthesizer is
trying to take its best guess at
how to pronounce certain words.
And of course, it makes mistakes.
However, Screen Reader users are pretty
resilient to these kinds of situations
because we often tend to look
at different web pages, and
words aren't always spelled
the way we expect them to be.
To make the long story short,
it suffices to know that Screen Readers
do provide a lot of shortcut keys, and
one of those shortcut keys is a way to
spell a specific word or
even a sentence, letter by letter.
So for example, if I did want to know
how the word Udacity is spelled,
I could simply jump to the place on
the web page where the word occurs.
>> Heading level, heading level 2,
contents, heading level 2,
4 items, history, heading level 2,
form control, 1 item,
headings menu, 1 item, heading level 1,
Udacity, heading level 1, Udacity.
>> And then I can press Ctrl+Opt+W to
have voice over spell this word out
for me.
>> Udacity, uniform, delta,
Udacity, U-D-A-C-I-T-Y.
>> So using the alternative spelling
is just going to teach me to spell
things wrong.
So please refrain from using
these methods in the name.
It will improve the experience
of Screen Reader users.